And now it's time to play
Tattoos of the Heart.
There are two kinds
of tattoos people get--
the ones where
a drunk person thinks,
"Hey, my navel
will make a great cat anus!"
and just in case you thought
we made that up, here.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
And the ones that have
personal meaning behind them.
Like, you had
a really important relationship
with your cat's anus.
Uh...
Just that special weekend
when you were snowed in.
And Mittens just kind of looked
at you from behind, like...
-(meows)
-No, Mittens, no.
(meows)
Meow, Flula, meow.
BORG:
No.
Stop it, Mittens.
Go back to your podium, Mittens.
Oh, fine, Mittens, fine.
-(hisses)
-Oh!
So comedians, I'm gonna show you
a picture of a tattoo
and for 250 points you have to
tell me the meaning behind it.
First up, this
curious sea creature.
This curious sea creature.
Huh?
Hungry for toffee, he's a shark.
What could...
What is that, Flula?
I think it's to promote
awareness
for shark type 2 diabetes.
Points.
It's a real problem.
Next, a childhood friend.
Huh?
It's a little Gumby
with a... eye infection? Uh...
James.
The story behind this
is that the guy
clearly got
catfished by Gumby.
Yeah.
-Points.
-You got to...
Flula.
It was, uh, supposed to be,
uh, Gumby fisting,
uh, but the artist
didn't hear it right.
Points.
Fi... Aw, come on.
Jen.
It's a guy
who's commemorating that
there's plenty of fish
in the sea except for him.
He's a weirdo, lonely loser.
Yeah, okay, points.
Points, points.
Next one, this
very painful receipt.
Right here.
(bell dings)
Uh, Flula.
This is so
he will always remember
where he conceived
his third child.
KIRKMAN:
Got a lot of stuff.
Points.
James.
This guy hates his dad.
His dad works at Wendy's.
-(bleep) you, Dad.
-Yeah, points. Mm-hmm.
Uh, next one, what about
this tasteful wrench?
This very tasteful wrench
right there. Jen.
That is someone who
needs to remind themselves
that they are a tool.
At all times.
Mm-hmm.
(whooping)
-Thank you, thank you,
thank you. -Good one.
Do you know this person?
It says #Berlin.
We have met once.
Yeah. Yeah.
Chill D Tattoo
is very friendly.